o método de hablar de economía en
francés 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero luís méndez luis
bienvenido iniciamos en china porque se
revelaron datos del crecimiento
económico a nivel trimestral
de acuerdo con el dato china se expandió
en el último trimestre 4,9 por ciento
una cifra menor a la esperada por los
analistas pero que no genera
preocupación en el gobierno los
analistas esperaban un crecimiento por
el orden del 5 por ciento los datos
mostrados reflejan una ralentización
respecto al primer trimestre que mostró
un crecimiento de 18,3 por ciento y el
segundo que cerró en 79 por ciento las
causas de la desaceleración están en una
baja del sector construcción problemas
de escasez aumento en el precio de la
energía y problemas en el sector
inmobiliario que está lastrado por la
situación de evergrande pero escuchemos
qué fue lo que dijo el portavoz de la
oficina nacional de estadística
en términos generales la economía
mantuvo el impulso de la recuperación en
los tres primeros trimestres sin embargo
debemos señalar que las incertidumbres
del entorno internacional actual están
aumentando y la recuperación económica
interna sigue siendo inestable y
desigual google dijo bueno y pasamos a
europa porque se vio un incremento en
los precios del gas una situación que de
acuerdo con la publicación en línea
europa pressa se presenta luego que la
empresa rusa gazprom declinó elevar el
bombeo hacia el continente de acuerdo
con la mencionada publicación los
futuros del gas para europa llegaron a
presentar un alza de 14% este lunes la
empresa rusa ha señalado que el
suministro seguro para rosa a niveles
récord y afirma un bajo nivel de reserva
de cara al invierno pero en otro orden
de ideas los precios del petróleo
también presentaron un alza este lunes
el petróleo brent cerró 84 dólares 33
centavos por barril por su parte del
west texas cerró a 82 dólares con 44
centavos el barril bueno y en eeuu se
dieron a conocer los datos de producción
industrial este corresponde al mes de
septiembre y mostró una caída de 1.3 por
ciento al tiempo que los datos de agosto
fueron revisado a la baja desde un
crecimiento de 0.4 por ciento los datos
del mes de septiembre en comparación con
el mes anterior se mostraron a la baja
debido de acuerdo con la agencia de
noticias ap a los efectos del huracán
aida adicionalmente uno de los sectores
que mostró una mayor caída fue la
automotriz que se desplomó 7 como 2% en
parte a la escasez de semiconductores de
acuerdo con datos de la reserva federal
por otro lado en el mes de agosto se
mostró una caída de 0.1 por ciento luego
del crecimiento de 0,4 por ciento
informado anteriormente y pasamos ahora
a argentina porque sindicatos peronistas
se movilizaron para pedir más empleo de
acuerdo con su visión esta sería una de
las maneras en la que el país podría
hacer frente a la crisis económica por
la que atraviesa además de solicitar la
creación de empleo los sindicatos exigen
una justa redistribución de la riqueza y
la reconstrucción de un estado presente
y regulador de la economía de acuerdo
con cifras oficiales argentinas que
presentó una caída económica de 9,9 por
ciento el año pasado presentó una tasa
de desempleo de 9,6 por ciento el
segundo trimestre del año
bajo desde finales de 2019 pero hay que
agregar que esto fue con una alta tasa
de informalidad bueno de argentina nos
vamos a centroamérica porque se
revelaron datos del comercio exterior en
guatemala según datos oficiales las
exportaciones del país presentaron un
crecimiento de 21 6% en los primeros
ocho meses del año 2021 en comparación
con el mismo período del año 2020 de
acuerdo con el banco de guatemala entre
enero y agosto las ventas al exterior
arrojaron 8.900 4,4 millones de dólares
en divisas las cifras representan mil
579 millones de dólares más que lo
alcanzado en los ocho primeros meses del
año 2013 bueno y vamos al mundo de las
cripto monedas porque el bitcoin mantuvo
su racha al alza recordemos que el
pasado 15 de octubre cerró por encima de
los 60 mil dólares y se acercó a su
máximo histórico de hace 6 meses elvis
con cerró en 62 mil 28 dólares en la
jornada esto en medio es la expectativa
de que este martes comiencen a
negociarse fondos cotizados en la bolsa
de futuros de pit coin y vamos con los
indicadores de la jornada el mercado de
wall street cerró con números mix donde
el estándar en push y el nasdaq
composite fueron los que presentaron
ganancias a lo largo de la jornada en
europa las bolsas se vieron afectadas
por los datos económicos de china además
de los precios elevados del petróleo una
situación que también impactó algunos
mercados japoneses américa latina'
sociales mixtos donde destaca el
crecimiento de argentina y chile- bueno
y cerramos con la cifra del día tiene
que ver en este caso con los 316
millones de dólares que será la
inversión de la empresa automotriz ford
en una de sus empresas en reino unido-
para la fabricación de piezas destinadas
a autos eléctricos después a usted
muchísimas gracias por esta ampliación a
ustedes por su sintonía continúen con
nosotros que hay más en france 24
[Música]